monsieur le Président Monsieur le
Ministre madame et monsieur le
rapporteur mes chers collègues au nom de
ma collègue Eliane assassy présidente et
de son groupe CRCE et oui au nom du
Président Guillaume Gontard et de son
groupe geste et des élus de mon groupe
sers j'ai l'honneur de vous présenter
cette notion tendance à proposer au
président de la République de soumettre
au référendum ce projet de loi de
financement de la sécurité sociale
rectificative pour 2023
de commencer par une citation
toute la bataille menée depuis le 19e
siècle se trouve ainsi résumé la
bataille pour le temps de vivre la
conquête du temps de vie quelle était
cette vie pour un prolétaire au 19e
siècle il n'y avait pas de retraite à la
fin de la vie il n'y avait pas de
journée de repos il n'y avait pas de
weekend
42 ans plus tard mes chers collègues ces
mots du président François Mitterrand
pendant sa campagne présidentielle de 81
résonne avec force dans notre hémicycle
il raisonne aussi dans mon histoire
personnelle moi enfant du Nord ce
département où les gens ont deux ans
d'espérance de vie de moins que la
moyenne nationale je sais ce que voulait
dire le mot travail dans le bassin
minier à Denain ou Douai dans les usines
textiles de l'île Roubaix au Tourcoing
ou dans l'industrie métallurgique à
Maubeuge ou Dunkerque
le combat de ma famille politique depuis
le premier jour a été de conquérir un
peu de temps de vivre il a fallu
toujours par tout temps sous tous les
régimes politiques arrachés aux
puissants les concessions qu'il
refusaient aujourd'hui se tiennent face
à moi ceux qui veulent revenir sur ces
conquêtes sociales toujours pour les
mêmes raisons l'argent la rentabilité
quoi qu'il en coûte sur le plan social
ce sont le président de la République
la première ministre est son
gouvernement monsieur le ministre les
majorités de droite qu'elles soient
relatives à l'Assemblée nationale ou
indiscutable au Sénat ces forces ne sont
pas simplement face à nous
parlementaires de gauche cela n'aurait
pas beaucoup d'importance elles sont
face aux Français en opposition frontale
aujourd'hui nous nous battons pas pour
leur arracher de nouvelles concessions
nous aurions préféré finalement nous
nous battons pour qu'il n'arrachent pas
du temps de vivre français que pour des
économies budgétaires ils ne mettent pas
en place un nouvel impôt sur la vie
d'autres politiques bien plus solidaires
sont possibles ils ont malheureusement
choisi l'injustice plutôt que l'équité
la retraite par répartition mes chers
collègues est un des piliers de notre
système de protection sociale ce sont
les luttes sociales successives qui
l'ont forgé les périodes historiques qui
l'ont renforcé on peut citer ici la
libération et ses jours je heureux et 81
et ses grandes conquêtes sociales avec
ce texte vous ne vous attaquez pas
seulement en français et vous vous
attaquez aussi un pan de notre histoire
certes il n'y a rien d'étonnant à ce que
la droite tente de détricoter notre
modèle social c'est même chanson de
commerce le gouvernement comme la
majorité sanatoriale sont dans leur rôle
le fer ainsi en revanche est inédit
choisir une procédure parlementaire qui
fait obstacle à la tenue d'un débat
parlementaire serein éclairé et sincère
pour une réforme d'une telle importance
sans parler des risques d'in
constitutionnalité cette inédit
fragilisez notre pays avec un texte qui
semble avoir été griffonné sur un bout
de table tant ces auteurs n'en maîtrise
pas des contours exacts c'est inédit
faire émerger un front syndical uni tant
la constatation est ratée sinon
existante c'est inédit réussir à
coaliser une écrasante majorité de
Français même parmi vos électeurs du
premier tour cette inédit je pourrais
continuer comme cela longtemps
[Musique]